Malik another day another victory for
you this is a dream first half at the
Nationals here tell us about your
feelings right now oh yeah I mean I'm
just uh I'm so pleased thank you thank
you Christian
um it was a difficult game um I had
difficulties to prepare because I wasn't
sure what to play like E4 D4
um
um and then I study a lot of Sicilians
then somehow I didn't like the positions
which you could appear like from
Scandinavian I thought oh my gosh too
much stuff so let me play something
simple something like for those just for
the game you know and then you guys
started thinking as early as move three
right because I think we both uh well
that's I mean personally I have an
expert at all he's more water all right
and I never thought he's going to be
playing that way yeah C5 for some reason
never crossed my mind it should be
because he's a zillion player and then
when he invited me to play London I said
okay if I play London that's what he
does every day you know so there is no
way I can play London and I play just uh
same as love reversed you know let's see
a tree and I said okay so no Advantage
but let's let's play on this was the
first critical yeah I was surprised I
thought after E5 it's supposed to be
like an invitation for me to like you
know to to attack I'm like yeah
but it seems like everything comes with
them exactly so yeah exactly and then
when he played that G4 that B3 Bishop B6
I couldn't believe I spent so much time
here but I couldn't find anything
decisive right perhaps it it wasn't
decisive there was nothing decisive okay
okay so yeah that's why no I think this
is 0.9 I see I see yes then I found this
idea with um
notified H4 uh couldn't F6 a bishop F4
so my my initial plan was to meet uh
Bishop C7 with capturing 25 and playing
F4
yes this looks good right yeah I thought
that's what I'm going to do and then I
said okay but what I missed uh I told uh
Max as well I thought he when he plays
Bishop equal H6 I saw the move I thought
I'm playing coolness 6 GH 94.
yes then I realized he does have really
nasty move check exactly yes yeah and
then I'll take take E5 and then I'm kind
of got scared oh yeah for a good reason
I mean King H7 right right I said no no
no no no I'm not gonna play that I mean
particularly against the max because I
mean he loves this type of sacrifice
he's an amazing Blitz player right and
they were all Blitz players are a very
strong tactically so I didn't want to
deal with that yeah because my initial
like plan for the game was to play dry
chest today just a solid positional
chess make sure you're not risking
exactly right yeah so HG Bishop F6 I
wasn't right I was hoping for Bishop B8
obviously but then he didn't play right
um so here okay he won yeah uh yeah
actually I thought engage seven is an
accuracy I'm not sure
yes I thought Bishop design was better
that's right yeah yeah it should be much
faster right because yeah I was so
concerned about Bishop D7
I was honestly concerned did you miss it
during the game or I missed and when I
was going for this position I missed it
yeah but then there's some Bishop D7 I
think I was going to do
um 94 actually here 94 here yeah
and if it takes oh I was I was fine with
that
something like rookie five yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I was hoping for that
I mean but Bishop December was
definitely the best move I was I was uh
scared now you're starting to have
something well yeah what's kind of okay
now I'm fine now I'm I'm uh I'm not only
fine yeah yeah yeah I'm not the worst so
if I take take FG uh G5 I think that's
the only move right yes otherwise I'm I
can't play slow but three actually this
is the way how I teach my students you
know in complex end game always like uh
play for threats but don't worry about
the engine too much I mean yeah is the
most natural way of playing right yeah
yeah G5 here check yeah King G7 yeah
here here here here
yeah this is the this is the critical
moment of the game in my opinion now
okay uh before H4 I could play uh Rook
F1 right
but this is a boring draw we can we were
actually looking at specifically this
line yeah it's boring draw just like
take yeah yeah whatever I take yeah
I said this is like just draw I I don't
want to deal with that luckily it seems
like it's yeah no but there's something
else I saw it it was kind of a line with
like equality uh yeah so I figured no
I'm gonna play for H4 so Rook C3 H5
Maybe I'm Wrong
I this is at least what I was focusing
on and my life was H6 King G7 not F7 I
mean Rook F7 King J yeah King G8 and
network F7 okay yeah
uh rookie seven check and rookie E7
check and okay
now you're probably yeah but it's
supposed to be drawn to draw yeah yeah
but I thought he he must play that but
apparently the computer will show
something yes I saw it right the bishop
B5 move Bishop B5 okay but this is yeah
but computers but I was very happy when
he played because he has low intending
me and uh here he was a lot of time and
he played Bishop it I was super happy
because this is what I wanted to take
take a gift to Yes actually I'm not sure
if you see this when I played uh King
gift 2 it was always trick uh with net
F7
instead of King F2 or no King F2 yes the
idea was let's say if he does anything
else I played the Knight F7 oh sure yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so he had to protect the back ring
uh-huh but actually a check is bad
I think the position is already
extremely difficult for him right so
what did I miss I mean it said my 1815
and that's what that's what Andrew told
me my kids
yeah he said coach you missed this mate
I'm like what now you're threatening
checks
I'm told for this and you're supposed to
be the main Bird Okay
King F4 still wins
yeah
I don't think you missed anything the
advantage was still within yeah
King G5 was good move right and after
that I think yeah yeah yeah nothing
actually happened yeah yeah it is no I
mean and again I knew they said it was
winning as soon as I had this setup I
knew this is like a lost
I had to make B like a little bit you
know uh careful obviously not to like
blunder
but obviously not like your your shape
is amazing right now how do you maintain
that for the second part of the event
well I made the changes before coming
here I mean last time I think when I
came here I prepared a lot I kind of
chest wise and my my brain uh wasn't uh
I guess you know good enough to actually
capitalize what I had to analyze before
coming here this time I took absolutely
off for six seven days I went to the
Mexico just to chill and vacation
vacation my wife told me just try to use
this laptop and what it divorce you so
and it worked out you know that always
works right I mean I spent time with
kids uh kind of uh feeling a lot of
energy and yeah I mean um yeah and
obviously honestly luck because if I
will lose to novikov you never know what
what will happen you know I get very
lucky against no because so I guess you
know somehow it starts on my side for
for a good tournament you always need
some luck so exactly yeah yeah that's
always the way it goes but I understand
pushing give it a day I mean every game
even it gets no bigger I could probably
play for draw with A6 but I thought I
mean just you know I wanted to fight I
wanted to play yeah you're definitely
bringing fight to the tables
congratulations on a great Victory we'll
see you in a couple of days thank you I
appreciate it